IT NEEDED 60 TO LAUNCH DEBATE.
THE HOUSE APPROVED THE BILL TWO
WEEKS AGO.
AS WE TOLD YOU EARLIER, WE
EXPECTED IMMIGRATION TO BE A BIG
PART OF TOMORROW NIGHT'S STATE
OF THE UNION ADDRESS, THE
PRESIDENT'S FIRST.
MIKE EMANUEL HAS THE LATEST.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP'S IMMIGRATION
PROPOSAL UNDER FIRE FROM
>> IT IS AMNESTY TODAY.
LEGAL REFORMS TOMORROW.
DOESN'T HAVE WORKFORCE
VERIFICATION.
AND ALSO IT'S REALLY AN
INVITATION TO FRAUD.
IT IS RIFE FOR FRAUD BECAUSE
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP ROLLED OUT
HIS PROPOSAL AFTER MEETING WITH
BLUEPRINT IS A STRONG START BUT
PREDICTS LIMITS ON LEGAL
IMMIGRATION COULD TRIP THEM UP.
>> THE RESIDENTS PROPOSAL OF
ALLOWING 1.8 MILLION DREAMERS A
DIRECTION.
HE DESERVES TO HAVE ACCOUNT TO
DRAW UPON TO SECURE THE WALL
SYSTEM, NOT JUST A WALL.
CHAIN MIGRATION AND CUTTING
LEGAL IMMIGRATION IN HALF, THOSE
WILL BE PROBLEMATIC AREAS.
>> CHUCK SCHUMER FLOATED
PROVIDING MONEY FROM THE BORDER
WALL BUT LATER SAID HE WAS
PULLING IT.
THE PRESIDENT'S PLAN.
>> WHERE THE BAD PART COMES IS
THE IDEA OF A WALL.
WHICH I THOUGHT WAS A GREAT IDEA
IN THE 15TH CENTURY WHEN CHINA
TECHNOLOGY THAT IS MUCH MORE
EFFECTIVE AND MORE
COST-EFFECTIVE IN TERMS OF
MEMBERS IN THE HOUSE IS OUT WHAT
IN THE U.S. BY JUNE 2012 TO
BECOME CITIZENS.
ON SECURITY, PROVIDING
AND CONSTRUCTION.
ONE POINT ONE, TWO, THREE
BILLION FOR NONBARRIER
INFRASTRUCTURE.
IT WOULD ELIMINATE THE DIVERSITY
VISA LOTTERY.
HOWEVER, HOUSE G.O.P. LEADERS
ARE NOT SUPPORTING THE PROPOSAL.
ONE POSSIBILITY IS THAT A
TEMPORARY DACA EXTENSION, ALONG
WITH A TEMPORARY GOVERNMENT